يمثل اليوم امام المحكمه في نيويورك
لابلاغه رسميا بتهم الموجهه اليه في قضيه
غاره اسرائيليه على جنوب شرق دمشق ومطارها
الدولي في هي الرابعه من نوعها في اقل من
اسبوع
مسيرات روسيه تستهدف ميناء اوداسا
الاستراتيجي في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
ينتظر ان يمثل الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب عصر اليوم الثلاثاء امام
محكمه منعاه لابلاغه رسميا بتوجيه تهم
جنائيه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لممثله
اباحيه لشراء صمتها وذلك في حدث غير مسبوق
لرئيس امريكي سابق وكانت رمب قد وصل مساء
الاثنين الى نيويورك حيث يخطط انصاره
لتنظيم تجمع حاشد صباح اليوم وقبل وصوله
الى نيويورك كتبت على منصته للتواصل
الاجتماعي
هذه حمله اضطهاد دولتنا التي كانت عظيمه
في يوم من الايام تتجه الى الجحيم
[تصفيق]
هذا هو الهدوء الذي سيسبق العاصفه سيقسم
الى هنا صباح الثلاثاء الرئيس السابق
وسيتوجه الى الطابق الخامس عشر في هذا
المبنى وهو مقر المحكمه الجنائيه العليا
في نيويورك
وسيقفوا امام القاضي والاجتماعي نحو اربع
وثلاثين تهمه موجهه اليه
بالفساد والاحتيال في مجال الاعمال ومن ثم
هناك سيكون عدد كبير من المتظاهرين في هذه
الحديقه
وسيكونون من مناصريه بالطبع ونرجو ونامل
الا تتسم بالعنف
مدينه نيويورك حضرت اعداد كبيره من
رجال الشرطه وهم اكبر جهاز للشرطه في اي
مدينه امريكيه
ولكنه وجودهم هنا معنا مع الصح مثلا
ومعنى في ناحيه الاخرى ومع زملائنا هنا
الذين يعملون وقربهم منا يجعلنا على
على اعصابنا في واقع الامر لان تاريخهم في
هذا المجال تاريخ معروف للجميع وتذكرنا به
احداث السادس من يناير عام 2020
هذا واكد عمدته ادمز انه لا توجد تهديدات
جديه على امن المدينه خلال محاكمه رئيس
السابق
وحضر عمده نيويورك من انه سيتم القاء
القبض على اي شخص يتورط في عنف خلال
محاكمه ترامب
مدينه نيويورك دائما مستعده نعلم ان
السلطات انفاذ القانون في المدينه يجب ان
تكون مستعده لاي شيء قد يحدث اريد ان اوضح
اننا لن نتلقى ايه تهديدات كبرى محدده
للمدينه خلال توقيت المحاكمه
التي تركها الطواعيه والتي تتحضر لمحاكمه
هي الاولى في التاريخ الامريكي الاجراءات
الامنيه مشدده هناك انتشار لحوالي 30 الف
شرطي في مدينه نيويورك طبعا من المتوقع ان
يستمر هذه الوجود المكثف لهذه الشرطه حتى
مغادره الرئيس ترامب طبعا هو سيقضي الليله
هنا في الت ومن ثم سيمثل امام المحكمه
الثلاثاء سيتم اخذ بصماته سيكون الاجراءات
قصيره نوعا ما سيستمع الى لائحه الاتهام
ويقول بانه غير مذنب سيتجه الى مطار
غواديا سيذهب الى فلوريدا وسيخاطب الشعب
الامريكي في خطاب لانصاره ومؤيته وسيقول
بانه القضيه مسيسه وهناك ظلم كبير وسيقوم
بجمع الاموال لحملته الانتخابيه
عبر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عن كامل
ثقته في قسم الشرطه في نيويورك وجاء هذا
ردا على سؤال عما اذا كان قلقا بشان
احتماليه حدوث اضطرابات اثناء محاكمه
الرئيس السابق
الاستعداد لمعركه هذا ما يقوم به الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دون ترامب قبل جلسه
محاكمته المقرره الثلاثاء وفق محاميه بحسب
محاميه ستحارب اي اتهامات ضد الرئيس
السابق بقوه وسيمثل امام محكمه نيويورك
لابلاغه بتهمه جنائيه موجهه اليه في قضيه
دفع اموال لممثله اباحيه بغيه شراء صمتها
من المتوقع ان يسلم نفسه للسلطات يوم
الثلاثاء ومن المقرر عقد جلسه استماع ظهرا
في منهات ولن تقيد يدا ترامب وبحسب محاميه
التفاصيل الاخرى للاستدعاء لا تزال غامضه
بحكمه انه امر غير مسبوق لا تزال تفاصيل
التهم بما في ذلك مهيتها وعددها طي
الكتمان وفق محاميه وسط نفيا بارتكابها من
قبل ترامب تقارير اعلاميه افادت بان ترامب
سيواجهه اكثر من 30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال
التجاري لدفع 130 الف دولار
في عام 2016 في محاوله لشراء صمتها بشان
علاقه جنسيه مزعومه وسائل اعلام امريكيه
ذكرت بان ترامب متهم بتزوير سجلات تجاريه
من الدرجه الاولى وهي جنايه بموجب القانون
الامريكي ومن المقرر تنظيم تجمع حاشد
لترامب مع النائبه الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب مارجريت هيلرجرين ظهر الثلاثاء
بنيويورك داعيه ان صار ترامب للانضمام الى
احتجاج سلمي ضد لائحه الاتهام رش خياط
العربيه
اذا هذه المحاكمه سببت توترات على الساحه
السياسيه الامريكيه وسط مخاوف من تصعيد
امنيا شبيها بحادثه الكابيتو
مع اختلاف طبيعه مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه بتهم
جنائيه واحداث الكابيتول الا ان هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ذات السيناريو فوضى وعنف
وتخريب رغم ان مؤشرات ذلك قليله وفقا
للسلطات الامنيه الامريكيه لكن لمعرفه
الاختلافات بين المناسبتين يجب اولا
التذكير باحداث الكابيتول
شغب الكابيتول حدث عام 2021 حين اقدم حشد
عنيف من انصار الرئيس دونالد ترامب على
مهاجمه مبنى الكابيتول في العاصمه واشنطن
احداث فتحت معها اكبر تحقيق في تاريخ
وزاره العدل الامريكيه ويواجه اكثر من 930
شخصا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم فيدراليه
الامر المشترك ما بين احداث الكابيتول
وبين مثول ترامب امام المحكمه بقضايا
جنائيه هو خطاب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لمناصريه لكن المختلف هو توقيت الخطابين
في احداث الكابيتول كان خطابه ناريا
ظهر فيه قبل ساعات من الواقعه واثار
المئات من انصاره اما فيما يتعلق بمحاكمته
في منهات فاعلن الرئيس الامريكي انه سيظهر
علنا بخطاب لكن هذه المره بعد ساعات من
سماعه لائحه الاتهام الموجهه له فحوى
الخطاب غير معروفه حتى الان لكن المعروف
هو تاثير ترامب على انصاره وفي المقابل
ردات الفعل غير المتوقعه للمناهضين له
احداث الكابيتول مثلت درسا للسلطات
الامنيه بدات بعدها بمسح امني واسع
للمشاركين وتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
بشكل اسرع وعلى الارض تجهيز مواقع الحدث
بحواجز معدنيه واغلاق الطرق وحتى قوى
بشريه ضخمه تغطي مساحه واسعه استعدادا لاي
طارئ
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب صرح
داخل الدائره المحيطه به بانه سيلاحق مدعي
عاما هاتا والذي تسبب في عوده واحده من
القضايا المنسيه
اسم يهدد مستقبل ترامب السياسي بسببه يمثل
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ام المحكمه
للاستماع للائحه اتهامات طويله
مدعي عاما
القضائي الجديد
تعتبر منسيه للعامه قضيه الممثله الاباحيه
ستوريز
صرح للمقربين بانهم مستعدوا لتصعيد
الهجمات والثاني من مدعي عام منهاجا
اشعر بالفعل الى انه سيلاحق مدعي عاما
هاتا قبل اسابيع من تسلمه لائحه الاتهام
وموصفه بالمختل عقلي
ومنذ ان اعلن عن ملاحقه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق بقضايا جنائيه وماليه برزت عده
اسماء مؤثره في هذه القضيه فالمتابع عبر
ابرز شخصيات المحاكمه التاريخيه دونالد
ترامب الرئيس الامريكي السابق يواجه لائحه
باكثر من 30 اتهاما بقضايا ماليه وجنائيه
[موسيقى]
اسمها الحقيقي ستيفاني كليفورد تزعم انها
كانت في علاقه مع ترامب قبل ان يشتري
صمتها مايكل كوهن محامي ترامب السابق تحول
لشاهد ادعاء رئيسي ضد ترامب
الفن براق مدعي عاما هاتن اول من قدم
لائحه الاتهام ضد ترامب
خوان ميرشن قاضي المحكمه العليا في
نيويورك
على هيئه المحلفين الكبرى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
افادت وسائل الاعلام سوريه رسميه بمقتل
اثنين من المدنيين في غارات اسرائيليه على
محيط دمشق مشيره الى ان الدفاعات الجويه
تصدت لاهداف معاديه في المجال الجوي
للعاصمه السوريه
واسقطت عددا من الصواريخ المرصده السوريه
افادى من جهته بوقوع انفجارات في محيط
العاصمه السوريه جراء قصف اسرائيلي ويجهل
حتى الان حصيله هذه الغارات
قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان الايرانيين
يقومون بارسال الاسلحه للضفه الغربيه
والحدود اللبنانيه وسوريا وغزه مشيرا الى
ان بلاده لن تسمح للايرانيين بالحاق الاذى
باسرائيل
نحن في حاله توتر على كل الجبهات
الايرانيون يرسلون السلاح الى الضفه
الغربيه والحدود اللبنانيه وسوريا وغزه
ايران تحاول تثبيت نفسها في سوريا وتحاول
شن هجمات ضدنا ولن نسمح للايرانيين وحزب
الله بالحاق الاذى بنا
في الاثناء افاد موقع اكسيس الامريكيه من
الولايات المتحده ناقشت مع الاوروبيين
والاسرائيليين اقتراحا للوصول الى اتفاق
مؤقت مع ايران ونقلت اكسيس عن مصادر قولها
ان الاتفاق تضمن تجميد ايران لاجزاء من
برنامجها نووي مقابل تخفيف بعض العقوبات
فيما اكد مسؤول اسرائيليه ان اسرائيل رفضت
هذه الفكره وايضا رفض الايرانيون الاقتراح
واكدوا تمسكهم باتفاق لا يقل عن اتفاق عام
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
استراليا تؤكد عزمها حضر تطبيق على
الاجهزه الحكوميه
اهلا بكم من جديد هاجم الطائرات مسيره
روسيه من اوداسا الاستراتيجيه الاوكراني
حسب ما اعلنت السلطات المحليه واكد
مسؤولون اوكرانيون في بيان ان روسيا
استهدفت منطقه اوداسا بطائرات مسيره
عسكريه وان الضرب اسفرت عن اضرار ومن
جانبها قالت
قياده سلاح الجو الاوكراني ان سبعه عشره
طائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من طراش شاهد
شاركت في الهجوم وذلك قبل ان تدمر انظمه
دفاع الجوي اربعه او اربعه عشره منها
في الاثناء اشارت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الى ان الجيش لم يحرز اي تقدم في مدينه
باخموت شرق اوكرانيا وذلك بعد ان قالت
مجموعه انها استولى تعلم مبنى اداره
المدينه ومن جهه اوضح الجيش الاوكراني ان
قوته صدت الهجمات الروسيه وما زالت تتمركز
في باخمت
اذا مشاهدينا كييف تنفي وتقول ان بخموت ما
زالت اوكرانيه فيما ادى او ادعى زعيم قوه
باقنر الروسيه السيطره على المدينه ورفع
العلم الروسي في وسطها فما الذي يحدث
حقيقه في اطول معركه في الحرب الاوكرانيه
انه ثاني من ابريل وخلفي يوجد مبنى اداره
مدينه باخموت من الناحيه القانونيه لقد
اخذنا باخموت وسيرفع قاده الوحدات التي
استولت على مبنى الاداره والمنطقه
المركزيه باكملها هذه الاعلام العدو لا
يزال متمركزا في الاجزاء الغربيه من
المدينه
كان هذا الحديث ليفديني زعيم قوات فاغنار
الروسيه حديث رد عليه المتحدث باسم
القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه الشرقيه
لقد رفعوا العلم على مراحيض رفعوه في مكان
مجهول علقوا قطعه قماش وقالوا انهم
استولوا على المدينه حسنا فلندعهم يعتقدون
انهم استولوا عليها تقول المعلومات ان
اشتداد حده التصريحات بين الطرفين يعكس
اشتداد حراره المعارك بينهما امر لم ينفه
ولا حتى الرئيس الاوكراني
الاجواء مشتعله في باخمه اليوم على وجه
الخصوص بالقرب من بيلوهوريفكا وكريمينيا
وجميع مدننا وبلداتنا وقران الاخرى في
دومباس
وفقا لتصريحات الجانبين فان المعارك تدور
على الضفه الغربيه من النهر الذي يشطر
المدينه الى نصفين في محيط مبنى مجلس
باخموت وسط المدينه اذ تتمركز القوات
الروسيه الى الشرق والشمال منه بعد
سيطرتها على المنطقه الصناعيه شمالا في
حين تتمدرس القوات الاوكرانيه في الجهه
المقابله غربا ومع تصاعدي سخونه المعارك
والتصريحات حول المدينه التي تشهد اطول
معركه في الحرب الاوكرانيه لا شيء مؤكد
فيها حتى اللحظه الا صوت الرصاص والموت
رائد المصطفى العربيه
حلم فنلندا بالانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي باتا حقيقه اذ اعلن مكتب الرئيس
الفنلندي ان البلاد ستصبح عضوا رسميا في
الحلف غدا الثلاثاء وانا جميع دولي حلف
الناتو البالغ عددهم 30 دوله صادقت على
بروتوكول انضمام فنلندا النيتو هذا واعلن
الامين العام لحلف النيتونا فنلندا ستصبح
العضو الحادي والثلاثين في الحلف مشيرا
الى ان انضمام فنلندا للنيتوس سيزيد من
امنها ويضيف قوه للحفظ الاطلسي
هذا اسبوع تاريخي للنيتو غدا سنععلن
ترحيبنا بانضمام فنلندا لحلف الناتو العضو
رقم 31 ما سيجعل من فنلندا اكثر امانا هو
الحلف سيزداد قوه كذلك السويد ستصبح اكثر
امنا وكان هذا نتاج الدعوه التي قدمها
النيتو لانضمام فنلندا والسويد للحلف
العام الماضي وكانت اجراءات اتمامها سريعه
بالنسبه للحلف وكلنا نتفق على ضروره انهاء
اجراءات انضمام السويد بشكل سريع
وردا على انضمام فنلندا للنيتو وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
من وجودها العسكريه على الحدود الغربيه
والشماليه الغربيه وان روسيا ستتخذ خطوات
اضافيه لضمان امنها العسكري عند نشر قوات
ومعدات للنيتوف في فنلندا
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسي
مستعدتان للوقوف جنبا الى جنب للدفاع عن
المصالح المشتركه وفي تصريحات صحفيه
لوسائل اعلام روسيه اعتبرها اللاعب راف ان
الغربه يسعى لافساد العلاقات بين روسيا
والصين
اعلنا مندوب روسيا الدائم لدى الامم
المتحده ناموسكم مستعده لتنظيم اجتماع بين
وزيري خارجيه روسيا والولايات المتحده
خلال زياره لابروف لمقر الامم المتحده في
اواخر الشهر الحالي في حال رغب الجانب
الامريكي بذلك وكان ممثل الامين العام
للامم المتحده ستيفن دو تشارك قد قال ان
الامم المتحده مهتمه بوحده مجلس الامن
الدولي خلال رئاسه روسيا في شهر ابريل
قال رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان قرار خفض
انتاج النفط الذي اتخذته دول اوبك
عفوا
لن يكون سيئا كما يعتقد وكان دول اوبك او
كانت الدول في اوبك بلس منها السعوديه
والامارات والكويت واصلتنه عمان والجزائر
وروسيا قد قررت خفضا طوعيا للانتاج حتى
نهايه العام الحالي كاجراء احترازي لدعم
استقرار سوق النفط
حضر وزير الدفاع السودانيه سين ابراهيم
ياسين من ان البلاد تمر بمرحله صعبه تحتاج
الى تكاتف الجميع للعبور الى بر الامان
وقد ذكرت وكاله الانباء السودانيه ان
ياسين دعا خلال حفل افطار بوزاره الدفاع
الى تجاوز حاله الانغلاق الانغلاق عفوا
وتوترات والانفتاح على الحلول الممكنه
التي تعمل على جمع الصف
اعلنت الحكومه الاستراليه الرسميه انها
ستقوم بحظر استخدام تطبيق تيك توك على
الهواتف الحكوميه وياتي القرار الاسترالي
بعد حظر دول عديده بينها الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا استخدام تيك توك من الاجهزه
الرسميه بسبب مخاوف امنيه
تحقيق جديد لشبكه سينان يكشف ان تطبيق
تسويق صيني يدعى بن دودو يحتوي على
برمجيات خبيثه قد تسمحوا لحكومه بكين
بالوصول الى معلومات قد تكون حساسه
تيك توك ليس هو التطبيق الصيني الوحيد
الذي اثار الشكوك حول استخدامه في التجسس
تطبيق بندود المختص في التسوق وضع تحت
المجهر بسبب استخدامه برمجيات مشبوهه
ايجابيه رئيس بندود والتنفيذي لا تعكس
الحقيقه القادمه التي كشفها تحقيق للشبكه
حول خطوره تطبيق التسوق خبراء الامن
الرقمي من فنلندا وامريكا واسرائيل فحص
التطبيق واجمعوا على انه يستغل تقنيات
تسمح له بتصعيد صلاحياته بدون اذن
المستخدم بندود الذي حذف من متجر جوجل في
شهر مارس الماضي بسبب البرمجيات الخبيثه
التي يحتويها يستطيع التلصص على التطبيقات
الاخرى الموجوده على هاتف المستخدم حتى
اذا ما قام المستخدم بالتخلص من فهو في
الواقع لن يكون قد حذف الا ايقونه التطبيق
خبراء الامن الرقمي الذين ساهموا في
التحقيق اكدوا انه يتخفى في الهاتف ويستمر
في رصد المعلومات وارسالها للشركه الخبراء
لم يؤكدوا بعد ما اذا كانت الحكومه
الصينيه تستفيد من المعلومات التي يحصل
عليها بندودو ولكن لدى بكين سطوه على
تطبيقاتها تمكنها من الوصول الى اي نوع من
المعلومات التي تريدها ان لم يكن اليوم
ففي المستقبل
انسنا ماسي العربيه
قال المفوض الالماني لحمايه البيانات اول
ريتش
ان بلاده قد تحذو حذو ايطاليا في حظر
محادثات
الروبوت تشات للحفاظ على امن البيانات من
مخاطر الانتهاك والتجسس
اوضح ايضا ان برلين طلبت من روما تزويدها
بالمعلومات بشان حظرها المؤقت الامر الذي
دفع شركه مايكروسوفت الى قطع الانترنت عن
تشات جي بي تي في المانيا
اعلنت الفلبين عن اربع قواعد عسكريه
اضافيه يمكن للولايات المتحده استخدامها
على اراضيها حيث كان احدها قريبه من بحر
الصين الجنوبيه المتنازع عليه واخرى غير
بعيده عن تايوان ما يثير غضب الصينيين
الذين يسعون للسيطره على المنطقه
اربع قواعد عسكريه امريكيه جديده في
الفلبين تثير غضب الصين
والتي تسعى للهيمنه على المنطقه بحسب
واشنطن
الا ان القواعد الامريكيه الجديده تعيق
الاهداف الصينيه
القواعد الامريكيه تقع بمناطق استراتيجيه
فالقاعده البحريه في مقاطعه كاكيان تبعد
400 كيلومتر فقط عن تايوان
اما القاعده الاخرى فتقع في جزيره بالاك
بالقرب من بحر الصين الجنوبي ليكون عدد
القواعد الامريكيه في الفلبين تسعه قواعد
كما يتم التفاوض بشان قاعده امريكيه عاشره
محتمله
بعد تشغيل الحرم المكي بكامل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه بموسم عمر هذا العام تركزت
عمليات نقل المعتمرين والمصلين من والى
الحرم المكي على منظومه النقل العامه بمكه
اذ جهزت 3000 حافله تعمل على نقل اكثر من
مليون و 200 الف شخص يوميا الى المسجد
الحرام وذلك للتسهيل على الزوار وتخفيف
التكدس المروري في طرقات العاصمه
[موسيقى]
مع دخول شهر رمضان
تضاعفت عمليات التنقل من والى الحرم المكي
وداخلي مكه ما جعل القطاعات الامنيه
والخدميه تعمل على تنفيذ خطط منظومه النقل
العام حتى تضمن الانسيابيه والراحه
للمعتمرين والمصلين احنا الان مشاركين
تقريبا ب 2350 حافله وعلى استعداد انه
احنا نوفر وفق الخطه التشغيل المعتمده
3000 حافله لخدمه هذه المنظومه بشكل كامل
المعدل اليومي لنقل الركاب تقريبا من
مليون الى مليون و200 راكب تختلف ان 7
وتفاوتها ما بين ايام في وسط الاسبوع
ونهايه الاسبوع خمس محطات نقل رئيسيه على
مداخل مكه التي تمكن المعتمرين والمصلين
من ايقاف مركباتهم واستخدام النقل العام
للحرم المكي اضافه الى تسعه مواقف نقل
داخليه تساهم في ايصال المستفيدين من داخل
مكه الى الحرم المواقف الداخليه هي مواقف
قريبه من الحرم
المده الزمنيه للنقل ما بيتجاوز العشر
دقائق من يوم ما يوقف سيارته الى ان يصعد
الحافله ومن ثم اتجاهه الى الحرم وابرزها
مواقف كتي ومواقف ساحه كدانه هذه من ابرز
المواقف بالاضافه الى موقف الزاهر
وموقف دقما الوبر في الجانب الاخر يعمل
مشروع حافله مكه على تقديم افضل وسيله
للنقل العام عبر 12 مسارا تغطي الشوارع
الرئيسيه والفرعيه والشوارع الممتده بين
الاحياء ويلعب دورا هاما في تقليل اعداد
السيارات في شوارع وطرقات مكه في موسم
العمره
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه
يمثل اليوم امام المحكمه في نيويورك
لابلاغه رسميا بالتهم الموجهه اليه في
قضيه
غاره اسرائيليه على جنوب شرق دمشق ومطارها
الدولي هي الرابعه من نوعها في اقل من
اسبوع
مسيرات روسيه تستهدف ميناء اوداسا
الاستراتيجي في اوكرانيا
دائما العربيه مشاهدين لمزيد من المتابعه
شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]